okay hi everybody welcome and good
afternoon I'm Dan ho sang I teach in
American Studies and ethnicity race and
migration that Yale I want to first
more.we interests the panel's thank
everyone for your continued energy
sustaining a conversation like this so
that we don't just drop in and off for
one paper but think about the collective
process of reflection and engagement
it's so important to this space so as
lovely as it is outside it's also lovely
in here and I really want to thank and
acknowledge and appreciate people for
that I was thinking yesterday about one
of the great things about staying with
all the papers is the way it allowed us
to move across the specificity of time
and place thinking about national
context in certain periods and how we
might kind of bridge that with larger
narratives and I think our three papers
today are cueing us to do exactly that
keep both in mind particularity z' and
continuities as we try to synthesize the
last two days of work so I'll introduce
the three speakers they'll do their
papers then we'll have some time for
questions first is Brendan McKeever is a
was a lecturer in the sociology of
racialization and anti-semitism Verbeck
University of London
he's also acting associate director of
the peers Institute for the Study of
anti-semitism and the author of a book
called the Bolsheviks and anti-semitism
in the Russian Revolution 1917 to 1919
and his paper is titled brexit class
racism in crisis then we'll hear from
Peru Yilmaz who is currently an
associate professor in the communication
department at Tulane University in New
Orleans he previously worked as a
journalist for a number of news
organizations in Britain Denmark and
Turkey he's the author of a relatively
recent book called how the workers
became Muslim immigration culture and
hegemonic transformation and Europe
which I just learned won an award from
Book Award from one of the sections of
the International Communication
Association
relations and his paper is titled the
elite and media rep response to populist
interventions and finally we're really
pleased to welcome David Seymour from
the City Law School University of London
David has written broadly about cultural
theories understanding and critique of
anti-semitism and his current research
project addresses the rise of populism
and its threats to the rule of law
equality and social and political rights
and he has a new title for his paper
it's populism elite theory and it's
critique so please join me now in
welcoming Brenda McKeever Thank You
Daniel and I want to thank Maury and
Steve as well for inviting me to speak
at this important event which could not
be more timely or urgent because we
gather here today a historic moment in
history of Britain and of Europe more
generally the neoliberal settlement
crafted over three decades by
conservative in social democratic
parties across Europe now lies in
tatters torn asunder by the most
sustained economic depression since the
1930s from Sweden to Switzerland Belgium
to Bulgaria a tide of reactionary
populism has been sweeping across the
European mainland a tide which demands
nothing less than a restoration of a
mythical Golden Age of sovereign
nation-states defined by cultural and
racial homogeneity now Britain has not
been inoculated from the turbulence
created by this decade long and still
unfinished crisis of late capitalism the
most striking manifestation of this of
course has been brexit now the talk I'm
given this afternoon is based on a
article I've written with Satnam Rodney
from the University of Glasgow which has
just been published in
ethnic and racial studies and while want
to do over the next 20 minutes of saw is
given a count of break so that places
questions of race empire class and
crisis center stage I'll begin by
mapping out some of the discursive
dimensions of the brexit campaign and it
will cause by offering a more structural
analysis that suggests and off words are
not an argument for why the brexit
narrative found such traction and why is
spoken to so many people just a couple
of things before we get started the case
for brexit was built around two distinct
organizations vote leave the official
leave campaign which was made up of
right-wing conservative politicians such
as Boris Johnson the second unofficial
campaign was leave EU and this was led
by the far-right party UK and its then
leader Nigel Farage a define and slogan
of the vote leave campaign was let's
take back control now this deceptively
simple demand was one that spoke on the
face of it to issues of sovereignty and
democracy but it was an argument deeply
entwined with the politics of race the
first thing to mention here his empire
for vote leave advocates like Boris
Johnson the brexit project was bound up
in the re-establishment of long-standing
ties with kith and kin from the old
Commonwealth of Canada Australia New
Zealand as well as the US and what
attracted many conservative politicians
to brexit was this idea of a revived
Anglosphere liberated from the EU
Britain would now be able to assert
itself once again on the world stage
indeed we need only cast our minds back
to the disgust of red
used by Prime Minister Theresa May in
her first address after braixen given in
January this year when she used the
phrase a truly global Britain no less
than 19 times no in the country with a
history such as Britain's you cannot
project a truly global Britain without
drawing on those deep reservoirs those
deep-seated Imperial residues booze and
nostalgic in search of a lost Empire
they continue to shape the collective
conscious of a large section of the
majority population now just to give you
a little flavor of this just before the
referendum you kept the far-right party
I mentioned earlier released a statement
saying and I quote outside of the EU the
world is our oyster and the Commonwealth
the peril within and last year during
post brexit trade negotiations with the
Commonwealth Whitehall officials
described these discussions as I quote
empire 2.0 an earlier this year one
conservative Minister displayed brexit
as strengthening of the white
Commonwealth this was off the record she
does now given this fanciful ambition to
embark on a new global adventure with
the British state as prima Center pylons
one might have expected but we've
campaigners to have undertaken at least
some reckoning with the underside of the
actual British imperial project of
yesteryear an acknowledgment perhaps of
colonial subjugation of the scars
material and psychic which have been
left on those stigmatized populations
over the course of four centuries not a
single word has been spoken to that
effect instead what makes this project
of a new global Britain so alluring as
precisely as arisia of the racist
underside of the actual Empire project
of yesteryear so the campaign for breaks
it then affected an artificial rupture
between Britain's historical past and
its possible future that is to sing
brexit draws on deep reservoirs of
imperial longing longing in the majority
population so the vote leave campaign in
many ways then was an exam part of what
Paul Gilroy spoke of as post-colonial
melancholy an additive crafted by in for
those who have still not come to terms
with the loss of Empire and the
resulting decline that Britain has
undergone since decolonization brexit
invoked
warm collective memories of a no lost
world where Britain was the global
hegemon of the capitalist world economy
those glory days when everything from
ships to spoons were made with a were
marked rather with a made in Britain
stamp the colonial flag may have been
pulled down in every corner of the globe
mr. Hall once said but it still flies in
the collective unconscious but running
alongside this fantasy of reestablishing
Britain as a global hegemon this vision
as Britain as the best in the world was
another set of narratives articulated by
the key leaders of the second unofficial
leave campaign leave EU their vision was
a different one of an initial on British
nationalism Britain for the British and
at the higher of this was a set of
concerns around immigration
according to Nigel Farage the then
leader W kept in the figurehead of leave
EU the EU had done great harm to Britain
by facilitating uncontrolled immigration
thereby suppressing wages a familiar
narrative the brexit campaign to get our
borders back to get our democracy back
to take our country back was underscored
then by a racialized vision of
restricting of restricting the entry of
undesirables to make Britain safe again
and this reached as crescendo just days
before the EU referendum when Faraj
stood behind this breaking-point poster
which depicted apparently Middle Eastern
refugees queuing up at Europe's borders
the subheading if you can see in red we
must break free of the EU and take back
control no unlike the Imperial fantasies
of the official weave campaign this was
a vision of island retreat of pooling up
the proverbial
drawbridge and as many pointed out the
image seemed to be pooled
straight out of the archive of National
Socialism more broadly
however the breaking point poster can
only be understood against the backdrop
of the way immigration to Britain over
the last century has been politicized
and racialized throughout the course of
the 20th century from the arrival of
Jewish migrants from Zionist Russia to
the migration of Caribbean and Asian
migrants there's always been a sustained
cross class coalition of social forces
that have opposed their presence in
Britain whether they were deemed to not
be Christian as in the case of the Jews
or not white in the case of Asians in
Caribbeans the British nation has long
been constructed in such a way that his
borders have been racialized in the
public imagination and this is what the
leave campaigners understood in a way
much of the mainstream media did not
because this history of immigration to
Britain has been so thoroughly
racialized over time their reservoir of
unconscious race racism could be
activated merely through the production
of appropriately framed and coded
language to put this another way around
people like Nigel Farage are able to
obey the formal rules of post racism
while at the site while at the same time
second signalling to their intended
public that they do indeed represent the
best chance of securing the old project
of keeping the nation Christian and
white so what underscored brexit then I
want to suggest were two interlocking
but actually quite contradictory
racializing visions one an expansionist
Imperial fantasy that sat alongside
another which was more initially a
project of Island Retreat know if
confirmation were needed that brexit was
intimately bound up with race it was
provided in the wave of racist hate that
was unleashed in the days and weeks
following the referendum result a report
in July last year showed that 6,000
racist hate crimes were reported to the
national police chiefs Council in the
four weeks following the brexit result
in fact in the four days following the
brexit result reports of racist hate
crime rose by 57% know the racism of
post brexit Britain has its moorings not
just in the inking loss of Empire but in
the structural decline that Britain has
undergone since the onset of
neoliberalism in the late 70s the
discourses of the leave campaign have
described so far assert themselves today
against a backdrop of Britain's
comparatively marginal position in the
world economy we're talking here about
the story of decline and decline is
important for understanding the politics
of the current conjuncture because
decline has also been accompanied by
defeat defeat of the labor and social
movements of the 1980s defeats have left
a working-class profoundly disaggregated
by region nation ethnicity and so on in
fact the period of working-class defeat
under conservative Prime Minister
Margaret Thatcher was accompanied by
another loss the loss of alternative
class frames of resistance including
those that were capable of
during the working class as multi-ethnic
and not just white let's go back a
little bit further after 1945 there was
a historic post-war settlement in
Britain that labor to a limited degree
would be protected from capital I'm
talking here about the NHS in the
welfare state of course and what
neoliberalism did however was to take on
and reverse that post-war settlement
under conservative rule in the 1980s the
politics of class even the language of
class and class solidarity were
significantly weakened and these defeats
in turn profoundly diminish those
counter currents of anti-racist politics
including those aligned to the politics
of blackness this is the backdrop to the
racialized class politics of the current
moment what has happened in recent years
is that the prospect and in fact the
reality of downward mobility has
produced class injuries and collective
experiences that have been recast to the
politics of result among other decline
is necessarily a multi-ethnic process is
experienced in a racialized frame and is
increasingly responded to by sections of
the majority population through the
politics of resentful nationalism
particularly English nationalism a large
scale sociological survey data actually
bears this out what are the drivers of
Englishness and English identification
today you know skepticism and concern
about immigration this kind of result
among is no longer defined by Imperial
Pro s or superiority but by a deep sense
of loss of prestige a retreat from the
damaging impact of a globalized world
that is no longer recognizable a world
that is no longer British to put it
another way around the decline of Empire
has not led to the overcoming of the
English
Tyrael complex but rather its
protraction into a defensive
exclusionary imaginary we are under
siege it is time to pull up the
drawbridge and as I mentioned earlier
this was one of the defining features in
the discussion of architecture of the
leave campaign but there's something
else to see here braixen may have acted
as an accelerant on those conditions
have allowed racism to flourish but it
did not create them instead they were
birthed not just under Thatcherism but
also the era of new labor as well like
other social democratic parties in
Europe labor has been complicit in the
consolidation of the racialization of
the nation and particularly the
consolidation of a new racialized enemy
within the Muslim there are numerous
examples in this long and saw detail but
I'll just give you one or two from
recent years on your screen here you can
see God and brown who in 2007 in 2007 as
Prime Minister demanded I quote British
jobs for British workers a slogan
previously owned by the far-right and
then in 2015 Labour leader Ed Miliband
continued the downward spiral of
racializing national politics by
pledging to control immigration and in
fact in quintessential British style it
was to honor labour campaign monk for
drinking your tea in the morning
controls on immigration across the
spectrum then from New Labour to
conservative a powerful narrative has
become dominant a narrative that
describes the principle lubbers
losers of globalization as the white
working-class now over the course of
this decade-long crisis the category of
white working-class is the frame through
which many men and women no understand
and make sense of their lives and the
real pain that they suffer a racialized
flame of white working-class victimhood
has emerged this category white
working-class elides the fact that it is
of course the brown and black members of
the working class who have been
disproportionately hit by the politics
of austerity and decline but when most
commentators and that a lot of them who
talk about their working-class or the
left behind a phrase that's come to
prominence of late what they have in
mind is a racialized class subject the
working the white working-class so this
category of the white working-class in
recent times in Britain has been brought
to life such that it now has a material
force with an everyday social relations
and we see this in the racist blowback
that's followed the brexit result of
June 2016 no I'm reminded of the fact
that the social theorist Raymond
Williams once remarked to be truly
radical is to make hope possible rather
than despair convincing well this has
been a despairing talk so where might we
locate some resources of hope well
potential collective agents against
racism in Britain today are not easily
identifiable but I do want to sketch a
tentative portrait of two possible
anti-racist agents first deposited in
the mine are in the minority populations
of England in particular our memories of
collective resistance any post brexit
push back against the racializing
narrowing or exclusionary framing of
Englishness will likely involve those
it's injuries it seems a banal point to
make but one was making second in a more
everyday sense there is hope to be found
in the very fact of multi-ethnic
contemporary life in Britain to put this
in a straightforward way which is much
more entangled in each other's lives
than was once the case nearly 1 in 10
people in England and Wales are involved
than what are termed mixed relationships
and nearly half of those involve people
from the majority white population so
the retreat of collectivism that has
come to define the neoliberal era has
also been accompanied by the emergence
of an everyday multicultural reality
particularly particularly among younger
generations those who are under 35 years
old we grew up in the slipstream of the
anti-racist struggles of the 70s and 80s
encounter Britain today transformed by
the very real gains of the anti-racist
movements that preceded them talking
here about equality provisions at work
multicultural education and schools an
anti-racist civic culture and so on
however much these gains have been
rolled back by the austerity program of
the current government their imprint is
traceable in the ease with which many
young people just handle the lived
realities of multi-ethnic life in
Britain especially in England in this
sense the anti-racist victories of the
past have their returns in the present
even though the political conjunction
could not be more different
for this everyday multicultural
sensibility that sociologists such as
Paul Gilroy celebrated has not I would
argue really been tested in a political
sense it's not clear on how durable the
lived multi-culture produced in the
aftermath of the anti racism of the 70s
and the 80s will actually prove to be
particularly when an Anita such as this
when the racist right is in the
ascendancy
the infrastructures of anti-racist
resistance are in long-term retrieve so
there are resources of hope but time is
running out we are at five minutes to
midnight thank you very much
so everybody I'm gonna talk about we
hire microphone okay we've heard a lot
of excellent and interesting
presentations about racism raised
anti-semitism populism fascism that then
with those objects I'm gonna talk about
something a bit different our responses
to those things and how our responses
actually somehow confirm what they are
saying and what they're doing and they
strengthen them so do you remember the
case where the scandal when Trump some
sexist talk about women where he was
talking about how he was dropping them
came up everybody in my surrounding said
he's done the media said that too
I turned to my wife she's there I said
no he's not
why did I no he's not because the
published logic is a krip to where it
could to deal with these things it's
anticipated soon that was the image that
was circulating on social media you
haven't seen it that happens not because
she actually I don't think she means it
but that is that is how Trump supporters
reacted to it because not only did he
survive the scandal nothing change
nobody who supported Trump actually
dropped him because of this it's because
the populist rhetoric the populist logic
as it were especially in its right-wing
variance I will be talking about mostly
right-wing populism not delivering
problem I don't I haven't studied that
much anticipate these kind of elite
hubris so this brings me what I'm gonna
talk about today our responses
to whatever they are saying actually
please write into police rhetoric
whenever somebody is trying to say
something expresses people through your
concerns they will be attacked by the
elite by the intellectuals the
government the media and they do they
the supporters do see them as our
pression of free the oppression of
expression of people's real concerns so
it doesn't matter she may even hate
Trump for sexual sexist speech but she
will still defend him the second is the
right-wing populist usually inside the
discourse about certain issues and our
responses actually focus on those issues
and by doing that not only do we confirm
populist arguments about elite hubris
but we also concede the ground on which
the struggle takes place which brings me
to my third point we end up sedimenting
the terms the categories the concepts
through which we think and practice the
social let me start with the first point
according to the police logic one of the
sins of the elite is that they act as if
they own the public discourse public
debate and decide what can be said what
can not be said consequently any attack
by the establishment is an attempt to
silent dissent against the system in
that sense populist leaders and not only
from Wallace before him love when they
are attacked they turned it around and
use it in their logic as a confirmation
that whatever they have been saying
about the corrupt system has been
confirmed
those attacks I've seen it I've seen
many interviews with people who support
Trump and a woman was saying for example
I'm afraid to say what I really feel
because it's not politically correct so
political correctness becomes a tool to
oppress dissent the mainstream media may
find those ideas outrageous but they
love controversies so they provide ample
space for these arguments for these
controversies and when repeated enough
these these ideas when they are repeated
enough they become so to say gentrified
they become part of the mainstream it's
now a legitimate concern just look at
what CBS our chairman and CEO said Trump
may not be good for America but it's
damn good for CBS I don't know if you
have seen it before I've never seen
anything like this and this is going to
be a very good year for us sorry
it's a terrible thing to say but bring
on bring it on Donald
keep going so how media works and up
they react to it feed into a tool opens
up space so that the media law
controversy I want to show you a clip
from Jon Stewart
of course the media was very circumspect
about whether or not they should even be
covering these provocative acts
perpetrated by propagandizing pyromaniac
proselytizers perhaps they shouldn't but
this next clip exemplifies how often the
media's better angels get kicked out of
them this guy is clown of the earth and
we shouldn't be having a conversation
about what he is or he isn't gonna do I
mean we can't address all these whack
jobs throughout the country and but
there's a second side of this Chris
that's really important
the Russell I've got to interrupt you
because here's the pastor
and knowing our and still undefeated
champion in the battle between the
media's super-ego and Eid is Eid for
media they can't help themselves not bad
people you know the media is there the
dog from the movie up like that's the
lady whose collar he is a good and smart
master he made me this collar so that I
may talk squirrel
pastor Terry Jones I don't remember I
don't know if you remember him he was a
pastor a far-right figure who was even
and strange from his congregation but
with this he became world famous and
suddenly his arguments were all over the
places and he was speaking to those who
may have thought the same things but
will ensure suddenly it was there in all
the media all the time even if it were
negative so what happens is let me play
this one now the media react just so you
know Wikipedia I made up that last part
all right well then I've left you there
was still some uncertainty as to how
Americans would be reflecting on the
ninth anniversary of 9/11 but
specifically how one American out of 350
million or so Terry Jones pastor of
Gainesville Dove World Outreach Center
and president of Gainesville's upper lip
hair Club for Men how he would be
observing that day will he burn the
Koran with his followers why is it that
Muslims are in such an uproar about
burning the crotch just how kooky is
this guy is he gonna start burning the
Torah next
Tora
[Applause]
so this one brings me to my third point
which is did you notice they were asking
why a Muslim so upset about it would
anybody ask any thing like that to other
religion so suddenly it becomes like I
don't know who that guy was and who he
represented but there was a Muslim thing
and there was a representative suddenly
it became into a category that you can
deal with so that is one of my points
it's not that focus on far-right
rhetoric and populist rhetoric means
that we upset their messages but we
concede the ground on which the struggle
they explain and then we also and this
is the third point accept the terms with
which we talk about it and let me give
you an example from my own an anecdote
from my own life a couple of months ago
I was invited to speak at a sponsored
panel about Trump's victory and the it
was sponsored by the academic
organization a huge economical position
the Chairman said we need somebody who
speaks off of from the Muslim
perspective I'm not doing that
but the point is why did she suddenly
assume that first there was a Muslim
perspective that one can speak of from
what would that be the second is that I
can speak of from that perspective so
suddenly we are dealing as she as an
academic I another an academic anymore
I'm off another category so having said
these things I want to talk about my
research that I did in Europe
especially about Denmark where there was
a published intervention in the mid 80s
and how it works it created a great
controversy but at the end they warned
even though they had lost the single
battle so let me see the case of Denmark
and this is the book that I had been
talking about so I'm gonna talk about
the research from the boat so that muck
is one of the first countries where the
published far right successfully
intervened in this course with the
nationalist and anti-muslim rhetoric and
gain immediate audibility
as early as the mid 80s what led to
their success was an intervention by a
priest called CERN cow in 1986 which
changed the focus of published far-right
forces from high taxes to immigration
special and wisdom immigration as the
biggest threat to the nation and to the
working class it came in the form of two
newspaper ads in September 1986 he and
small group of people around him
successfully created a huge countries by
saying these things around by calling a
boycott of an iconic humanitarian
parading campaign for Refugees it was
called refugee 86 he claimed to be
speaking on behalf of silent majority
who he said were deeply concerned about
the future of their nation the corrupt
cosmopolitan elite were about to destroy
the nation by letting Muslim immigrants
flooding the country and destroying it
he asked the Danes
by court refugee 86 as a way of
resisting the elite done so this is an
abbreviated form of that ad you can see
what he's saying there
the question is done why would this
argument by a relatively unknown priest
and columnist who was known mostly for
his extremist homophobic and mr. John ik
misogyny misogynistic views have so much
impact on discourse
call he easily be dismissed and rendered
irrelevant that's where the rhetorical
strategies come in and I think by
talking about those rhetorical
strategies I'm hoping to create a kind
of format that will give us an
understanding of how our reactions feed
into it or don't fit into it so the
first strategy is creating controversy
but as a way of opening up the discourse
for themselves even if the controversy
is not painful so he was able to create
a controversy as soon as you create a
controversy as we have seen with Terry
Jones you become the main protagonist
even if you are criticized so the ads
and the following fulmination
immediately brought him into the center
of debate heated debate the media
coverage was extensive he received an
incredible amount of space in which he
promoted his arguments very few people
had seen the ads within a couple of days
everybody in Denmark knew what he was
saying every single person and of course
not surprisingly his ads brought the
entire establishments together the
mainstream left and right labor unions
employers artists writers intellectuals
of all sorts and of course the media how
could they not Refugee Council was
composed of representatives from
different humanitarian organizations so
as such it represented the humanitarian
self image of Denmark so you see it
seemed inevitable that it
create animosity against him so they
thought the most effective strategy was
to accuse him of racism Josh just like
George Wallace in in the States or any
Powell in the in Britain he cleverly
turned around these accusations and used
them as a proof that the cosmopolitan
elite were indeed terrorizing Danish
people and that racism was an effective
tool in dismissing people's concerns so
it became one of the central tools in
his strategy of polarizing the debate
and channeling the resentment against
refugees into a general dissent against
the political and cultural establishment
as well as the political representation
system which what something I called
hegemonic crisis another rhetorical
strategy was constructing people through
the figure of silent majority this is so
generic actually for almost all populist
movements so what it does is it allowed
him to present himself as the brave man
who spoke on behalf of those oppressed
majorities since they were silent he
dared to speak up his articulation of
those concerns became the factor
particularly the factor concerns of
those concerns actually I read um a lot
of letters to editors in that time
people did not talk about Muslim
occupation they talk about money we
can't afford so many people what are we
gonna do we don't have housing they gets
bicycles we don't get bicycles that kind
of stuff and there was none then
expressions of Islamophobia but they
were not the main concern but he said
forget about all that money stuff we are
talking about the future of nation and
that became the taste definition of the
prow
so by the here's the TV twist though he
did not really focus on those concerns
in these ads is that he DRI directed the
attention of his opponents to something
else he attacked a humanitarian aid
campaign that had nothing to do with
Danish immigration policies the money to
be collected were to be used for
refugees abroad not refugees who had
already arrived in Denmark so this was
the greatest return to trap and the
opponents swallow debate without
thinking twice it seemed easy to defeat
him on that ground by taking the bait
the opponent involuntarily admitted that
the aid campaign as the battleground
so money collection does became the sole
criterion criterium for success it had
to succeed so in hindsight how could
they avoided a failure in money
collection would be seen as disapproval
of immigration laws and policies and in
general as a confidence board on the
political representation system so by
making money collection as the main
criteria for success what they did is
they they let his basic claim that go
unchallenged the logic was this even if
people were dissatisfied with
immigration policy they could still
donate money since the task is to help
refugees abroad not in them so ok I did
not
so the leader of the refugee council the
main nemesis of him said it's probably
correct that people are not happy about
the refugee influx to Denmark but then
they should be more willing to
contribute because the task is to help
refugees out in the world
almost everybody repeated this argument
so the opponents where exactly where
crowd would help them they accepted the
claim that the immigration policy was
immensely unpopular and they also
accepted that immigration was not only a
question of economic burden for people
but a question of a threat cultural
threat to the nation by not challenging
him on this premise they granted him
free hands to articulate what
unpopularity meant that Danes were
concerned about the future of the
donation this became the definition of
the problem of course the collection was
relative success the goal was reach even
the foreign minister from the mainstream
right was among the volunteers who
collected money but does it mean that he
was really defeated on the contrary
since the mid-80s
Muslim immigration their cultural
incompatibility with Danish society and
the threat they posed to the welfare
system and everything else we had been
fighting for among others
gender equality freedom of speech
tolerance for gays whatever you can
imagine as progressive they were threat
to that
so the fara is sustained campaign it
didn't stop here on the impact of Muslim
immigration has moved to political focus
from class to culture as the natural
ground and which solidarities are rooted
consequently the strange bedfellows have
emerged as I said even the left and many
progressive movements accepted the
premise that the future of the nation
depends on a successful defense of the
core values of the nation threatened by
Islam
let me show you this is a logo that one
of the most liberal newspapers in
Denmark that has always been against
far-right and against Islamophobia users
when they have a theme about immigration
try to see what's going on the
constellation women with headscarf as
opposed to emancipated women and
emancipation signified by little clothes
the same here it's there's an abundance
of these pictures whenever there is a
story about immigration
so immigrants became Muslims they were
guest workers they were workers as
workers they were part of the working
class in Denmark as Muslims they are not
part of anything anymore they are alien
they are outside of society they are not
part of the ontological structure of
society so this is what happened and
this was these pictures were from 90s
and 2000's and this is past for 2015
Danish Social Democratic prime minister
in her election campaign she says if you
come to Denmark you have to work
refugees and immigrants and social help
have to work I want a connectivity where
everybody contributes to it so they are
speaking the same language this is
social democracy this is not far out and
this is actually the left-wing response
to it if you come to the sadhana
you have to pay taxes so they were
trying to challenge and then I must say
I've seen homes showing some statistics
yesterday and it seemed as if the
far-right is not successful it is
actually it's the second biggest part of
it because of the representation system
which is where the young level is 2%
only you have a lot of parties they are
the second biggest party and not only
that they actually have
an enormous impact on how we think about
society but the latwon who never went
over four percent with this they came up
to eight or nine percent so there is a
polarization so my time is up but I want
to wrap up with one paragraph that is
when we respond to publish logic of
populist rhetoric we always respond with
facts and rationality politics is not
always about rational deliberation it is
actually as we think usually it is an
investment in identity categories and I
will think of identity is usually about
solidarity who and with whom and about
what the reports old art is with people
and how is it if defined those interests
that around which we can force all the
artists of course by the adversary who
is preventing us from achieving those
ends so depending on who the adversaries
and in this case its immigrants then the
solidarities are fought on the basis of
cultural sameness nationality race race
is not a big thing I mean in Denmark is
culture so with that I'll end and I hope
that this can provide us with some kind
of map where we understand how the
published logic works and how we can
respond
[Music]
[Applause]
firstly I'd like to thank all the
organizers for the conference
someone said about a successful
conferences you meet old friends you
make new friends and you learn something
in which point this has been the perfect
conference being last of the panel of
the conference has its disadvantages
I was going to give up smoking it has
its advantages in that it gives me an
opportunity where I think I see it of
connecting with other papers so in a way
it's been quite a good thing and
especially this panel I think my work
fits in nicely with the two previous
papers I'll say I'll read to start with
anyway despite the varying divergences
within the literature of popular
literature on populism there is almost
unanimous agreement that at its poles
it contains two components the elite and
the people Cass Mott formulates that it
as follows populism says something about
the relationship between the elite and
the people this paper explores these
three elements of populism the elite the
people and the relationship however it
does so not like most recent literature
from that of the people but from the
perspective of the elite
I think it's from that perspective that
some new light can be thrown on the
phenomenon the phenomenon of populism
moreover I've chosen three critical
works to throw light on this question I
argue that the trouble with a lot of the
critique of populism is that we accept
too much of their concepts and of their
narrative that we are not critical
enough so in a way this piece that I'm
presenting today is a gloss on [ __ ]
Hinds 614 commandment which is don't
give any victories to the reactionaries
as they say it's a gloss I argue that
these critiques remain in thrall to the
phenomena that they're investigating
they accept at face value rather than
challenge the claim of populum populism
image of the demise of the
meaningfulness of representative
democracy and the social relations on
which its premise yet despite that I
argue that the critics themself have
something important to say the three
works I've selected or rather revisited
are what I think are three of the best
works of elite theory which is dialectic
of hope at an electic of Horkheimer
Adorno would love that a dialectic of
enlightenment by Adorno and Horkheimer
the power elite 1956 by Searight Mills
and Ralph Miliband's Ed's dad in the
state in capitalist society in 1969
this isn't part the presentation but in
the actual paper it's not just a
substantive link in terms of their work
but there is an academic biographical
link between all three which is quite
interesting to find so the first section
the ambivalence of the elite within the
current literature on popular
as I've noted most contemporary work on
populism has focused on the notion of
the people one of the consequences of
this focus is the seeming ambivalence
toward the related and often mentioned
concept of the elite this ambivalence
expresses itself in its slippage between
being portrayed as the invention of the
populist imagination and its supposed
existence as a concrete reality of the
nature of modern politics and governance
this turns in the case of in Jan Verna
Mueller's recent book what is populism
he identifies what he sees as popular
zooms three inherent criteria and he
elitism anti pluralism and an
exclusionary ident area notion of the
people yet for him and he elitism barely
is worth reflection in fact he
naturalizes concepts of the elite as
part of the functioning of modern
politics as he says I argue that it is a
necessary but not sufficient condition
to be critical of elites in order to
count as a populist otherwise anyone
criticizing the status quo would be
definition be a populist also virtually
every presidential candidate would be a
populist if criticism of existing elites
is all there is to populism after all
everyone runs against Washington
likewise casts mud from the same work
where he makes the definition of the
people and the elites of times the elite
appears in inverted commas as it a false
concept or a false construct in the mind
of populism and at other times he treats
it as an actually existing thing yet so
what I find about the critiques of
populism is when they refer to the elite
it already grants to
much explanatory power to the populist
imagination
indeed it grants too much power to that
which it should be fundamentally
challenging what I'll do now is very
briefly go through elite theory and the
relationship of power that unites it
with the people writing of elites
origins in the late 19th century Garant
Perry notes it's corresponding to two
important aspects of the rise of what
came to be termed the administrative
state the first was the expansion of the
franchise and the rise of mass politics
and the second was the expansion of the
state's role in almost all aspects of a
citizen's life taken together these two
developments created an increasingly
powerful executive along with an
expanded centralized bureaucracy able to
fulfill that new role of the state but
for present purposes what is important
to note is this this early elite theory
claimed to identify the locus of real
power
they said this is where the real power
lays in the body politic that is with
the unelected executive in its
bureaucracy rather than in the
institutions processes and interests
represented in the corresponding
democratic institutions
likewise along with the content of elite
theory was its adoption of a positivist
methodology which I won't go into too
deeply but they literally posited this
location of real power and so on and so
forth and we get that today in some
elite Theory work that that's being
written now taken together therefore a
picture of elite Theory emerges that
bears a striking resemblance to the
image of what populace say is the true
nature of the modern body politic no
longer explicable in terms of the
relationship of
civil society and the social relations
that give meaning to both their fall and
their content the image for both is a
critique is a false or is a form of
governance that is said or posited to be
in the hands of the few the elite and
stripped bare of what they see as an
empty facade of democratic or Manama
tation has almost omnipotent power the
relationship in order to as so as to
order the now passive lives of the many
ie the people the three critical counts
I mentioned above appear at first sight
to reject such a positive reading of
elite theory they're more sensitive to
the temporal historical and social
movements that bring elites into power
yet despite such sensitivity the picture
of the populist imagine his imagination
is replicated for Adorno and Horkheimer
the rise and power of the elite and
corresponding decline and powerlessness
of the non elite emerges from the
usurpation of the state by society's
dominant ruling class the bourgeoisie
brought about by the concentration of
private property into the decreasing
number of cartels and corporations see
right mills who shares many of Adorno's
and Horkheimer thinking on this points
dates to these developments from the
onset of the Cold War however unlike the
Frankfurt thinkers Mills does not claim
that the state has disappeared but
rather for all meaningful intents and
purposes comprises not only the
industrial elite but as we know also the
military and political elites and
following on for Mills Miliband refers
also to an economic elite but one the
shares of values and interests of a
capitalist infuse state elite where
there is a meeting of
notwithstanding the important
differences between them all three
thinkers relate the rise and Dominion or
domination by the elite with the coming
into the mass or what in its populist
version is the people and here I want to
draw on on Brendan's word which he just
presented on the racialization of that
concept of the people I think he's dead
right and I and I would like when I
speak to the people I'd like to bear in
mind Brendan's points on that
the point is expressed most clearly in
the power elite where Mills writes the
rise of the power elite rests upon and
in some ways is part of the
transformation of the public's of
America into a mass society Mills
explains the transformation from a
liberal to a mass society from a
democratic to an elite understanding of
society in terms similar to adore Adorno
and Horkheimer I've got a list here it's
a fragmentation of the subjectivity due
to division of labor empty consumerism
the medium as a cheap television
consumerism and so on and so forth but
taken together for mills and fur Adorno
the effect of the rise of the elite is
set to ensure that the non-elite
internalized what Mills refers to as
life adjustment and to what Adorno and
Horkheimer call more darkly subjects
without subjectivity to put the matter
in other terms the mass or the people
are characterized by the hallmark of
passivity and conformity and again our
Brenda mention isn't among result Amon
was mentioned yes
today I can't remember who it was I
forgive me but when I was rereading this
last night ready for today I remember
neech's Maxine that's a right aphorism
the man would rather will nothingness
than not will at all and I think that's
relevant with this notion of passivity
and conformity if there is agreement
between populism of a world divided
between the elite and the people and of
critical theory or the critiques of it
that see them well in a similar term the
elite and the mass so to is their
apparent agreement on the nexuses of the
relationship between the two
I knew I was hot okay sorry for that
interruption thankfully it was nothing
serious and thanks for for sticking
around so here's what we're gonna do
David is going to finish his paper he'll
recap a little bit to get us back in the
mood we'll have a short question period
and then we will go straight to the
keynote after so thank you and I've
always wanted to do this previously this
I'm exactly cry for Sutherland to run in
now that the basic theme of the paper is
that the critics of elite theory accept
the pot the destruction of what they see
as the political world as that between
an almighty omnipotent powerful elite
and a completely and utterly powerless
conforming mass with real power in the
hands of the few and where what I was
going to now speak about is once they've
broken down that relationship between
the elite and the people or the mass
what they the argument of the Nexus of
the relationship is pure power
unmediated power so what I say here just
to find it the nature of the
relationship presented is stripped bare
of any of its democratic aspects
legitimacy Authority and has instead
expressed through the positivism of
power or more likely domination and I go
through
adora I won't bother with this but I run
through how that happens in Adorno and
Horkheimer where it's a unilateral form
of power but moulds of the mass and even
though it's slightly more moderate in
mills once again everything is stripped
bare democracies are in representative
institutions notions of social interests
social relations are completely erased
which I argue is insert the heart of the
populist imagination I'll actually
probably only be five minutes so I'll
just finish with this bit about power
despite the emphasis each places on the
top-down direction of power as the nexus
between elite and people or vert elite
and the people if there's always a
definitive article all present that
notion of power in a positivist
possessory manner as little more than a
zero-sum game game of gains and losses
with the elite the ultimate powerful wit
winners and the mass or the people their
ultimate powerlessness losers so in
keeping with the theme of the conference
what about racism it's interesting to
know that in these critiques of elite
theory there's very little discussion of
racism other than in dialectic of
enlightenment as far as I'm aware
Mills does not mention racism at all in
the power elite and this is written in
1956 and it's only mentioned in passing
in Miliband's the state in capitalist
society yet where it is mentioned
especially in dialectic of enlightenment
racism and anti-semitism is explained as
not inherent in the relationship
and the people but rather as its
by-product so for a door loan hyck hyck
homer for Adorno and Horkheimer the
passivity of the mass all the people
turn into the racism of the people
underneath the surface its presented
through the prism of psychoanalysts the
Jews in inverted commas the concept of
the Jews become for the people the
embodiment of bourgeois subjectivity the
promise of freedom individual agency
control over their own lives which has
to be repressed in order to fall for the
people for individuals subjects without
subjectivity to survive in the era of
monopoly capitalism under understood in
these tones therefore embodying as
embodiments of these very values or
elements the mere presence of inverted
commas the Jews become a provocation for
a present and a future emancipation that
cannot be but endlessly deferred and
denied for Miliband and and again this
taps on to Brendan's paper for Miliband
it's a failure and frustration of an
available and credible alternative to
the way things are a failure which he
argues is brought about by social
democratic while he calls social
democratic elites adopting the values of
the contemporary capitalism and which
therefore these are ground free for a
would-be demagogue to come along and
make profit out of it but what I argue
is that these authors fail to recognize
that racism anti-semitism is not a
byproduct of a system that said to exist
between the elite and the people or the
mass but rather it is inherent within
that relationship the critique of
populism appears to accept the claims of
the populist in man's imagination in a
manner that mythologizing
the complexity of social and political
relations so the political and social
phenomena become reduced to seemingly
the personal machinations of the view
it's precisely how populism describes it
it identifies people as the carriers of
power as the passivity and the powerless
of powerlessness of the mass
rearticulate sit self as the power of
the people they cannot but imagine
themselves victims of such personalised
elites who the embodiment of such elites
are will of course vary from time to
time and place to place yet whoever is
allocated this malevolent almost
omnipotent if not magical power they
cannot be and this taps into an earlier
paper alexandra's I think they cannot
but be deemed as the enemies of the
people be they the cosmopolitan elite
the global elite in England we had a
terrible headline where the judges of
the Supreme Court will called the
enemies of the people the bankers the
Rothschilds the lobby and as we saw in
an earlier paper it's the elite the
personalized people of Ely who are
blamed for bringing in the non people as
well as it's always mediated through the
elite for populism and those of its
critics both of whom appear to share
share the same account of the reduction
of the state and civil society to the
elite and the people respectively and
who in so doing flatten out the
contradictions and tensions inherent
within both of the former concepts into
opposing for modulus groups no other
explanation
remains the conclusion I'll only be a
couple of minutes conclusion in this
paper I've hoped to hit illustrate the
ways in which
three critical counts accounts have
accepted many of the fundamental
assumptions of both elite theory and the
role it plays in the populist
imagination in other words the critiques
of populism have failed to obtain the
necessary critical distance adopting the
positivism of elite thinking as I say
the state becomes the elite civil
society the mass or the people and the
relationship in terms of power
however the correspondence between this
critique of elite elite theory and the
populist imagination is not without its
truth value it tells us something about
the times we are living in there is
little doubt that Adorno and Horkheimer
Mills and Miliband captures something
real and tangible about the age in which
they were writing and I am speaking yet
their error if I may call it that was to
present their theories as if they were
examining blows of fate of which we are
powerless to act it's as if what the
powerful was saying about their own
power and the powerlessness and the
powerless about their own absence of
power was truly the case rather I
believe that each of these accounts
Express again this is pure coincidence
of the fathers and Brenda's vapor rather
I believe that each of these accounts
Express what we can call the politics of
defeat and despair they capture
something tangible about the areas in
which were they were writing they were
periods of reaction in which the
political and social tide had turned
against more progressive streams the
despair brought at these times appears
in the content of the accounts of the
world that is adopted by the forces of
reactions themselves and which as we've
seen also inform the
populist imagination the demise of the
democratic institutions and the
conflictual social relations that the
sustain them and their rise in their
place of a mythological division between
elite and mass or the people the despair
also appears in its positivist framework
in which what perhaps kaliesha can and
should be seen as a temporary and
reversible reversible moment in the ebb
and flow of social forces and social
interests have become frozen so that to
paraphrase Adorno and Horkheimer it
takes on the image of brute facts or
blind fate which we tell ourselves we
are powerless to alter this
powerlessness forbade not only elite
theory and the populist imagination but
also constrains a praxis of a democratic
critique a practice in which we are all
by definition invested and consequently
responsible there in the age of Trump
and of brexit the temptation of populism
to explain such an age should appear is
hardly surprising however for those who
are palpable
however for those who oppose such
explanations of the world it is
important that in not falling under
populist and spell we do not grant it
the very power it grants to itself thank
you
[Music]